hey Theo and Brennan this is Tanner from
Fayetteville Arkansas whoo damn Pig I'm
one of the 30 people in the state who
have internet so I'm using it to ask
these questions
it was survived longer in prison between
you two Oh hold somebody's pocket and
some of that mouth warm with smooth
creamy peanut butter they said it would
take a my own 600 years I got out of
there say a prison time but burning shop
did it in less than 60 dreamin right
listen the problem is let's go be let's
don't live it Derek isn't Morgan
Freeman's son first of all look like
Morgan Freeman bro who would last long
in prison I think we got to go to the
culture corner man because white people
are definitely me I'm imprisoned an
all-time high right now so and like I
can't join the white supremacist yeah
ooh damn okay damn you're too tall dude
rule number one about being a white
supremacist they're not short work low
bro you know I'm saying you want to be
the guy Iggy you know cuz it's all want
to get hit first here's the other thing
remember before you answer Theo has long
hair smooth skin and no tattoos he looks
like a lady carry on
answer Wow I think the only way field
survives is yeah keep from sucking [ __ ]
don't say that kind of stuff at the end
at the end of the night he starts
telling one of his theall stories before
they rape him and ever he's like oh
finish your story and he's like I'll
finish tomorrow
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I don't think I'll be on something
either one of us to do very well in
president no do you would be a little
[ __ ] Christmas turkey in prison boy
yeah dude I kind of know how to fight
gonna be that's our picture prison going
for you the first minute well you can't
go 40 seconds without talking about
another man blowing another man dude now
when I look at you also look well I'm
sweating like I'm going to prison yeah
what you're saying cuz you can't even
handle the question you can't handle the
truth
boy yeah I all met I wouldn't do well in
this guy say that first of all you are
bigger than me bro your butt is bigger
than me and your behold your B hole is
bigger than mine your mouth is bigger
than mine and your nose is very feminine
yeah but you can't my nose nobody's
gonna they're not like oh who's that
sexy rabbit with thank you grab your
here come on bro
yeah dude you're going down bro yeah I
might get shanked at least I'm not
getting butts in my face yeah what's in
what your dick no dude I got take it
there man people are putting butts in
your day I don't know yeah I've never
been a prison dude
yeah isn't my problem is I don't know
who decide with it's a race war in there
I'm so blacks don't like me I look kind
of Mexican but I'm not mixing I don't
speak Spanish
bro whites don't like me yeah you're
that tall Mexican little [ __ ] fun
bunny that's all you know ones are we
going fun buddy they're looking at you
going that's a fun rat I'm saying with
long hair and a [ __ ] big old bottom
lip that thing's got the bubonic plague
yes what they're saying they're not
gonna be coming at me what do you think
cat come on cat who's who survive in
prison I feel like people would bum-rush
Brendon and then I think Theo would get
away with slinging Goods like ramen like
I feel like he'd be resourceful like
Terry Crews in the longest yard he's
that guy who could get you McDonald okay
so you're saying that Brendan would
definitely get attacked well you would
be like a meet-up for dicks no no she's
not saying they would rape me she's
saying they would kill me oh you think
yeah
yeah then I run a train on me they run
the Train gonna be super friendly to you
and then slowly like that's just a
[ __ ] and they see you know oh wow
okay it's just with my mouth no you can
think that now it's with my mouth for
sticky buns okay you want a Twinkie now
it's in my butt that's how Brandon it's
slowly it's a snowball of gayness in
prison Jesus Christ dude you're just
really different than you used to be
don't ask me about prison bro if you
don't wanna know the truth
you can't handle the truth oh I already
use that you're like two minutes
yeah you can't handle the truth and you
can't handle crunchy peanut butter so we
need to survive in prison mates crunchy
died sitters bumps in the road I've
converted you to crunchy bumps in a row
thank you [ __ ] autobiography bro
here's what I'm saying is this you think
if Brendan's gonna get killed in prison
cat first of all being awesome they're
gonna have sex before they kill you
nobody okay you're not they're not
Psychopaths and the good owners they're
not librarian there's still people Theo
you're an idiot sorry you're not an
idiot but you pretty much also are one
you're an idiot you don't think you're
your mouth is getting raped within two
minutes of Brendan dude can we get to
the next thing this is to get this guy
is
yeah 7% Theo yeah no [ __ ] what was the
question who would survive longer in
prison gang boy the rats
yeah because you be sucking the boys el
reyes day right on crunchy sucker you're
sick man what else are got no more dick
talk all right
try my best yeah try your best
[Music]